hello and welcome to the daily climate
show coming up
after the fires the drought farmers
already struggling with a lack of
rainfall are worried
[Music]
thousands evacuated as a wildfire blaze
is out of control near yosemite national
park in the states
and reading fc unveils its new strip
complete with global warming stripes
[Music]
welcome to the daily climate show where
we track the changes happening to our
world hear from those affected and
reports on the race for solutions
and we start today with concerns that
the record high temperatures we
experienced last week might be setting
us up for a summer of drought across
england other dramatic images of fires
across the country over the past few
days and this is the aftermath of the
fires in surrey yesterday and they've
added to fears of water shortages now a
dry spring and early summer have already
reduced river and reservoir levels
pushing much of the country into
prolonged dry weather status now whether
or not we reach the technical definition
of drought the extended dry conditions
are already causing serious problems for
farmers katharina vitotse is in north
yorkshire for us today
this is a 300 acre hillside farm in
north yorkshire typically this isn't the
sort of location where water is a
problem but the farmer who works this
land and rears sheep and cows says he
can count on one hand the number of
times it's rained significantly here
since spring and the impact of that on
the land
is grass and pasture that looks like
this it's absolutely bone dry there's
barely any new growth and typically
you'd expect grass at this stage of the
year to still be around this height and
the impact is that there is very little
for the flocks and the sheep and the
cows that graze this land there's very
little for them to eat and the farmer
keith stone's been describing the sort
of impact that has on his livestock but
also his livelihood we can't grow the
grass that we need to feed the animals
we're really struggling to grow enough
crops to make crops for winter for the
animals to eat
and there's nothing now for the animals
when they're needing extra for the
autumn time there's nothing for the
lambs when we take them off the mothers
the rest of july and all august two of
the drives won't steal the crumbs so
it's not as if a shelter rain's going to
put things right now it's a long time
before we're going to get the autumn
rains that will probably correct things
would be then you know it might be too
late for feeding the animals for winter
this is a fifth generation family farm
and keith stones who you heard from in
that clip says that he cannot remember a
prolonged dry spell like this since the
1970s and really whether or not this
prolonged dry spell turns into an
official drought is somewhat
insignificant for patches of ground that
already look like this the grass is
beyond saving it is already dead but
what will be key is whether there is
enough rain in the next few weeks to
enable new planting for new grass to be
able to germinate and then grow because
that is what will go on to feed
livestock over winter and for many farms
will be the difference between making
some sort of profit this year and not
okay let's get a bit more of the day's
climate news now and in greece
firefighters have contained a wildfire
on the island of lesbos after three days
while a heatwave continues across much
of the south of the country fire
warnings remain in place and national
parks have been closed to the public at
the deer national park in the northeast
of the country authorities are trying to
contain a wildfire that's been burning
for five days
now the world's first ever heat event to
be named has been detected in spain's
fourth largest city seville just a month
after the naming scheme was launched now
authorities have warned that heatwave
zoe could bring temperatures of up to 43
degrees celsius today and tomorrow the
scheme to name heat waves in a similar
way to severe storms was launched to
raise awareness of the dangerous effects
of heat on human health with a
three-tiered category system
reading football club has shown off its
new home kit that integrates climate
stripes and is made from recycled
plastic bottles now each stripe
represents the average temperature for a
single year so shades of blue indicate
cooler than average years while red
shows years that have been hotter than
average now the stripes on the reading
fc shirts specifically track climate
change in the cities across the full 150
for one year existence of the club
now a wild fire near california's
yosemite national park has forced more
than 6 000 people to flee their homes
and has already burnt more than 15 000
acres of land a combination of droughts
climate change and overgrown vegetation
increases the chances of fire spreading
rapidly now the start of the wildfire
season comes as more than 85 million
americans are living under excessive
heat warnings that's across the country
now according to the u.s drought monitor
more than 63 percent of the country is
currently abnormally dry that's
affecting cattle of course and crop
produce and in california those
conditions have exacerbated wildfires
across the state over the last few years
now while the blaze near yosemite is not
yet under control officials now say
firefighters are making progress guys
sally lockwood uh reports
4404
[Music]
but the scale of this one in mariposa
county marks an unnerving start to the
wildfire season
on the doorstep of yosemite national
park home to some of the largest and
oldest trees in the world
the fire has ripped through a handful of
rural homes and businesses but threatens
thousands more
and remains out of control
they came by about 15 20 minutes ago and
told us that everybody's got to go about
4 o'clock the power went out
and the fire has been coming towards us
faster and faster
a huge evacuation order is in place more
than 6 000 people have left their homes
already as the fire traveled at
frightening speed
spitting out embers that fell as far as
two miles away
this wildfire comes as a record heat
wave is sweeping the united states with
heat warnings and emergencies declared
in several states
everything that's burning in the fire is
extremely dry we know that
california has been dry the last few
years and has gotten drier we just asked
that the public be patient if their
neighborhood or their community has been
affected by the fire it will take a
little while to notify them if they have
if their residents have been affected
climate change is driving the ferocity
of these fires the intense heat and
worst drought in decades spanning the
flames
but so far america has found no
political consensus on a way forward
that will do anything to prevent more of
this in the future
sally lockwood sky news washington
and before we go is there anything you
want to know about climate change what
confuses you or mystifies you we'll scan
the qr code on your screen right now to
submit your questions to us and we'll do
our best to answer them or you can go to
any of the sky news social media
accounts where you can add your
questions in the comments so get in
touch with us well that's all for now
for today we'll see you soon thanks for
watching
[Music]
you